what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to start
She-Hulk today yeah and of course John
how are you doing I am great I'm so
excited koi it's been a while since
you've been in a video with us
we'll go check out Corey's comic Corner
maybe have theories coming out for this
episode today follow him on Tick Tock
where he's got 15 second to three
minutes I hear your intros I edit them
so he'll say it Corey I'm expecting you
to bring your comic expertise whenever
there's a character that pops up on
screen you better instantly name them or
else you don't know Comics first
appearance name Alias and Adventure
leave a like Hulk smash that like button
also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next She-Hulk is up
also full-length Reaction watch Longs we
need to sync up with your own copier
over at our patreon page for super sexy
rejects cover some shows exclusively
over there with the same tier you get
the option for reaction highlights watch
along is included lastly prepper well
thank you guys so much for helping us
these down koi show them your triceps
triceps prepper now the other one's a
lot bigger that's still pretty big nice
I'm really white Greg I know it affects
you you're gonna get a tan let's do this
[Music]
the defendant used their Limitless
resources for financial gain at the
expense of Public Safety
your litigator that their power shielded
them from very real consequences
shielded and you and the case and you
are not helpful here Adam but I will
kill you and general prosecute only
because it's a conflict of interest not
because I condone murder you're going to
listen to a paralegal over another
lawyer he means a woman over a man I
almost cried during parts of it now you
just have to top it off with a Savage
Jen Walters look what I don't have a
Savage Jen Walters ah Savage She-Hulk
reference it's it's good I picked up on
that too it's subtle
they only said it twice
um it's true I am a Hulk uh and I'm
guessing I'm guess I'm gonna be able to
focus on this fun lawyer show until you
know all about that so
immediate fourth wall break Cheetos and
Chopsticks yeah so you don't get
don't get stuff back to what I was
saying before my theory oh god um Steve
Rogers let's let's all act like we
haven't hurt seen this scene yet
everything that I've already told you
about my friend and golly obviously
Captain America
that's your ship from zakar right yeah
ouch kind of felt that there
[Music]
inhibitor
oh my god
[Music]
wow that was such a fast transformation
yeah
[Music]
oh girl what happened to you
are you okay okay no judgments but
whoever did this to you does not care
about you
I have to call my cousin to get me can I
borrow somebody's phone
we all deserve a squad like this one the
friendliest little bar hey we're just
being friendly yeah you too good to talk
to us damn you guys are aggressive
foreign
[Laughter]
fixing myself and integrating the Hulk
Banner identities
in this tiny Beach House lab yeah yeah
Tony built it for me a few years ago
Tony Stark
[Music]
do we hit a spaceship yeah it's a car in
class A couriercraft they're probably
trying to deliver a message I got to get
to the bottom of that you know weird
stuff just kind of found you a girl
foreign
I've been analyzing your blood and the
way it synthesized gamma I was able to
use it to completely heal my arm because
I'm better than you
um it's basically different
my arm is healed and now I'm able to be
my fully integrated self again
smug
I just got my own office I have business
cards there is no going back to what you
were before
oh
[Music]
Man
Hulk looks great yeah I'm like that [ __ ]
in end game right
just stay here until you you figure out
how to control your Hulk self well how
long is that gonna take about 15 years
give or take 15 years top priorities to
control when you turn
foreign
Jacks in
put on a Pixar movie when Bing Bong
jumps out
[Laughter]
even he was like
triggers are anger and fear
they're like the Baseline of any woman
just existing all right then let's try
this
hmm
dark Tech
feels like if I don't transform I'm
gonna die do you have a plan B for that
uh no this is gonna kill me
they go die make your choice
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs
wait wait you're still you're still gen
right now
yeah you're the only only one in there
as far as I can tell this is huge and I
think I'm jealous is that what I'm
feeling
this time it was so intense I could
barely remember what was happening but
it's like it's settled in hmm
well
you can just skip all that then
how do I turn back into Jen how did you
do it
I think I'd fall out of a jet or I get
knocked out by a robot and I'd wake up
his Banner
Natasha for a little while would tell me
a lullaby walk me through how that
worked again
I don't have a great explanation for it
just regular anger means death and
Destruction for everything and everyone
around you and I'm telling you when
people start seeing you as a monster
that never goes away wow
teach me how to Hulk
please teach me how to hook to teach me
how to Hulk first we're going to
practice some mindfulness with a few
yoga techniques it's more about presence
about accepting the situation you're in
Oh I thought it was about getting my
butt tight as hell
gross Jen and your cousin just close
your eyes and breathe all right
[Music]
who's your best friend Mickey spandex
[Music]
just trying to show you how it's done
asks for balance
[Music]
laughs
it's easy
all right all I've been doing is showing
you the downsides of being a hawk but
there are a few upsides
my body's metabolize alcohol
that we can drink so much and knock it
drunk
yeah
[Music]
the Hulk's an alcoholic
I mean kind of
impressive yeah me and Tony
not Tony mostly drank just sat around
like complaining about Steve oh Steve
ah this is ruining the post Civil War
time yeah
when do you think I
can't believe let's just focus on each
day as they come Jim
cat called in the street when
incompetent Men explain my own area of
expertise to me so all of this just
feels like projecting a lot of [ __ ] onto
me
no I'm doing this oh okay this is
completely new territory
I bet that little thing she was
lamenting is gonna go over well with
everybody
oh I bet a lot of this is gonna go
everybody yeah the show in general is
going to be below
you're now a superhero and who's gonna
protect the world if it isn't People
Like Us are you quoting a comic book
right now
laughs
I'm serious you're not the only one but
you think you can just say a bunch of me
things like that and then take off yes
[Applause]
[Music]
did I kill the Hulk
[Music]
oh here we go
[Music]
damn Bruce for the record I really
didn't want to do this
oh Thunderclap
[Music]
that's all you got
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
get that nut
oh no not the bar
so if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer I respect that
[Music]
something wrong with me she's kind of
hot as the Hulk oh no I've definitely
got a thing
call me anytime thank you Bruce thanks
very much
a breaker's mine I'm sorry that I said a
bunch of harsh but very
very apology that still doubles down on
a thing you're apologizing
I've seen that horoscope meme a thousand
times
I see a fuzzball
I really like them together I like her a
lot too
I was right and Bruce was wrong and I
never have to be a Hulk okay
so now I'm gonna go in this case
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
oh my God early entrance
I really love that delivery
[Music]
Jennifer Walters attorney at law
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mm-hmm
I'm ready to give my closing argument
now
[Music]
foreign
where's Daredevil
you know
he'll be the lead soon I thought he was
the star looks like they set up that uh
World War Hulk movie
yeah I think uh we might see other
characters like looking for Hulk games
you mean the ship from sakhar it's a car
yeah I wonder if someone's looking for a
new champion
or it could be a son you think he did
they do him scar banged in the last two
years come on man that's why they set it
up with the Captain America virgin thing
she's like a la based hero we need them
I don't know if I learned that oh my God
we gotta postgres
sex
[Music]
deserve to die virgin
Steve Rogers is not a virgin he lost his
virginity little girl in 1943 on the USO
tour
knew it
you're not drunk Captain America
Natalie Dormer [ __ ] Captain America all
time girls one of the best currencies I
don't care what anyone says that was one
of the best songs
thank you
so good
I said uh trailer reaction I was like I
bet he bones someone during World War II
right yeah I was thinking right back to
that chat we have the Natalie Dormer
scene I I feel like they boned
the girl who was hitting on him in front
of Peggy yeah yeah
let's only talk about that all right
Captain America this totally changes the
Integrity of his character
I thought he was a dedicated Christian
way until marriage yeah
corner
coil comic corner post coitus
now we'll find out that
Sam is actually the virgin of the
Captain America yeah
all right well I enjoyed it I enjoyed it
um I think I got some things I don't
want to be too positive let's leave that
to you guys yes I'll be the edge Lord
what's your negativity Greg oh no I'm
reserving let's get all the negatives
out of the way firsthand yeah get
everybody on our side yeah yeah yeah no
I'll I'll I'll I'll reserve it I'll be
the one that [ __ ] douchebags that
have a problem with women are mad at I
think the exact people that need to hear
the things that she had to say are gonna
be the exact ones that get mad at this
show and I'm glad they made it uh I
think that like this character has been
around since the 70s
oh it's coming but I don't give a
[ __ ] doubling down uh Stan Lee made
this character before he left and came
back to Marvel this was the last
character Stan Lee made before he left
and resumed and Stanley was always about
seeking inequality uh justice for
inequality seeking equality Stanley was
always about making sure that people
felt like they were represented and I
think She-Hulk somehow in 2022 is still
terrifyingly relevant so I love the fact
that there were examples of how she
would be superior in some ways and
that's going to be the biggest we're
gonna see [ __ ] 32 commentary we're
going to see all sorts of like why was
she able to beat up the Hulk all of that
[ __ ] and I think it's important to
acknowledge that women do have to deal
with anger and emotions differently and
I think it's important to acknowledge
that this is a character based on
emotion they had literally invented the
Hulk to be a force of what rage embodies
a man like they they
um I think it was red was the original
color that Stanley wanted Hulk to be but
the ink wasn't as good so it was green
and then gray happened because of a
similar like printing quality issue the
Hulk has always represented what it's
like when when you can't control rage
and I love the idea that She-Hulk
represents like yeah they are better at
controlling anger than we are because
they have to because society says don't
be emotional woman so I loved the first
episode
have you met enough women I don't know
any women because what's a woman they're
out of control they're lying to you Coy
that's part of their master plan to gain
control over the world they're
constantly I think they're oppressed I
constantly thinking the way I talk about
them is is It's upsetting no and I'm
like cool your horses ladies yeah just
smile a little bit
come on
silence
fourth wall breakup silence uh I just
love how you I just love how you kicked
off with that as if that was gonna be
the thing I was gonna say
okay
I'm kicking off with the thing that's
gonna be everyone's commentary I'm
kicking off what I think we're gonna see
on what Friday this drops on Thursdays I
think we're gonna wake up to Twitter on
Friday saying all the [ __ ] I just said
so I'm kicking it off with like what's
gonna be [ __ ] trending yeah
um no I mean that's that's already
happening before this ever it came out
all right
yeah it's gonna happen
um no I mean I I do I appreciate the
context of that once this is the first
subject I guess we're going there uh
since uh yeah I do appreciate the
context of that I do think that I was
having a little bit of issues with the
pacing at first and I kept kind of like
Marvel for giving it that's that's how I
call my forgiveness of Marvel sometimes
which is like this is her narrative
she's doing a flashback story so it's
just going by a little quick for my for
my taste it's going by a little fast and
then I did like I don't mind the context
of that at all uh it was really the
parts of the Way It Was Written seemed
like okay so all her angers only based
in the fact of how men treat her of
these little things so some of it felt a
little bit I would have liked to have
seen anger be more than just that yeah I
agree with you yeah that was main that
was my qualm with it not like freaking
you're throwing [ __ ] in my face it was
more like it's a little
mixed and more layered and I'm sure
that's an aspect of your anger but maybe
not the entirety of Warriors like a
corrupt court system
large being problematic Beyond just men
in it like yeah there are others yeah
and uh so and so some of it was moving a
little bit faster because overall
there's a lot I liked about like I I
think um and I feel like you would
attest uh to this this is me looping
John in the conversation so I did that
guys leading the conversation no I
didn't even notice nobody sits in the
middle the was that
um I really love uh Tatiana maslani
that's her name right yeah I think she's
excellent I think the way how they've
gotten you know Iman villani and Tatiana
woman Gettys your names so I could
remember them and pronounce them easier
why can't they all be Tessa Thompson
yeah it's something simple yeah like a
Jane or something right no Ahmad Milani
and uh Tatiana maslani wow there's a
real ring to those uh I think they've
done like amazing casting with both of
them here and she's excellent like
instantly immediately endearing like you
do buy the history that oh yeah she has
been his cousin her whole life right
their whole life they might have met a
year ago like we don't know when like
maybe they were friends whether they
could have met a year when the actors
met each other because like they they do
embody that history and they're such a
natural chemistry with them like you
were pointing out we were watching Again
Luke and John in was that they have that
that history with each other and I think
she already brings
so much life to this character and I I'm
enjoying what they're doing with
um uh like her having this dichotomy
that I think is an actual pretty
I think it's a very realistic dichotomy
the way how you had like Spider-Man like
I want to be a teenager and go to school
but [ __ ] I'm a superhero too and then
she's already dealing with that
complexity where because like this is
something that just kind of happened to
her and she has to throw her whole life
away when her whole purpose was driven
off of her career especially like a
lawyer in Los Angeles like that's really
going to be a thing that I'm this is
everything I've dedicated my whole
existence to and now I gotta sacrifice
that like how can I make both of that
work I think that is a really uh
interesting thing to explore I do think
in terms of the She-Hulk side
God damn it the second the thought came
I was like no no people are going to
think I'm saying Mary's too I'm not
saying that uh I'm saying that I do
think at times it was come and maybe
it's is like this in the comics is maybe
that's the maybe that's my Marvel
forgiving way of doing it guys that's
how I forgive all Mary Sue's out there
well I think I personally sources I
think they wanted to get to the lawyer
stuff and not to be a training show she
did kind of pick up on everything a
little too quick for my taste though you
know what I mean I don't disagree and I
and I like what you said about more than
just mad at me like there's other things
to be mad at I don't disagree with
either of those things yeah it's
interesting I feel like there is
hey guys
uh no no I do think that there is a bit
of a bingo card unfortunately that
people are going to be sitting there
checking off in their own little Rage
Cage and that was something that made me
wonder because yeah I mean it's
obviously like a very self-conscious
aspect of the conversation surrounding
any female-centric con content anything
like this that involves power and it
makes me wonder if they're going to use
it in any way or extrapolate on it later
because yeah like I shared a lot of the
same kind of just a little earmark notes
and what you call Marvel forgiveness I
also call like comic book forgiveness
there are certain like you can I feel
like in a comic book specifically you
can more sort of easily throw out like a
big outlandish High concept thing and
have it be like oh yeah one Minor Detail
in a sequence of many
but uh I want to see what they make out
of that because the strength for me was
yeah I liked all the scenes fast though
they were moving I liked you know the
conversations the Rapport between the
two of them like I think this really
sings in terms of character but it does
make me wonder because there are so many
things that people actively whinge about
constantly about Mary Sue's and other
things that are all like very much
displayed here in a way where I'm almost
like I wonder if that's intentional
partly to rile up the people who are
going to complain about that but also
maybe they will you know use it as
something in the story form to
extrapolate upon or something or at
least that's my hope as this goes
forward yeah because right now what I
think they've done a really good job at
fleshing out nothing really external
struggles have we really got into
because it's like oh she had a she had
an issue to deal with and seems like
she's getting really excellent handles
on the issues really fast in terms of
the physical stuff what they've really
done a good job of fleshing out is her
internal all struggles and to me that is
arguably more important I don't even
feel like it's arguably I feel like
usually it is
more important than than the physical
side of things like so I really I really
like one aspect of what they're doing I
think the acting's really good I think
the comedy for the most part is is
really hitting and I I like the way
they've set up like for if you look at
it just as a pilot I think it's a really
set up strong where oh I I wonder what
the journey is going to other than my
trailer knowledge I wonder what like the
journey will be and what it's going to
feel like episode to episode moving
forward I really enjoy the fact that it
feels like episodic TV I really like
that some of the Marvel shows have been
like we're gonna be a long movie cut in
parts and other shows have been like
we're trying to tell a story and
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
this feels like a show and I kept
marveling at how impressive the CGI was
uh because the show budget is you know
different between shows and movies and
this is something airing on Disney plus
and I was really impressed at the fact
that it looked like a Hulk like I really
enjoyed Hulk on screen She-Hulk
definitely got a lot of improvements
from the trailers and there is an
inherent
um uncanny valley to something that has
a brooding brow and stubble and more
texture than you know a Hulk we're used
to versus a seven foot woman that's
effectively green like it's harder for
our brains to go like that's almost what
a person looks like versus that's a Hulk
and and the Marvel Mark Ruffalo mapping
has had more years to do it so it makes
sense that the Hulk looks
a little more fleshed out pun intended
then the She-Hulk because they've only
had like the six months torque on it
we've been hearing all about the visual
effects stuff at these major Studios and
all these things like developing in real
time uh you know there's some anger
there's some frustration oh dude and
they're just they're overpaid at those
places
now they're just sitting around
listening
just willy-nilly drinking pina coladas
we love you but like how impressive is
it like they announced this show what a
year ago we saw the trailers and there
was a lot of like you know upsetness and
now this looks great like I was
impressed I love the way it shot I love
the tone I love the pacing uh there is a
little bit of pacing issue with the
speed of the Montage but I think it
effectively set up a show that is now
going to have uh we have the
relationship between Bruce and Jennifer
established we've got you know how much
she loves her job and now we can have a
lawyer show and we have this set up for
World War Hulk and maybe the setup
no yeah and I think it uh I mean not to
overshadow the theories but uh but no I
think it like as it got into like the
one after the episode you want to talk
about the
the actual episode not the future do you
want some Easter eggs there's me there's
that there's an oh yeah break down the
finale now if it's not this I don't like
this show these expectations give me
exactly what I wanted there was no
Daredevil at all where's yeah
as we got to them I mean I'm curious
about how that stuff is gonna go because
a lot of the Hulk action I thought
looked really good and then the titanium
scene at the end was a little bit like I
hope we can kind of make these action
scenes feel as good as those acting
scenes but for the most part the the
second half of the episode felt really
smooth and like we reached this cruising
altitude where like it didn't feel so
fast anymore so I'm hoping that yeah
maybe that's just getting used to the
pace of the show overall my three
biggest flaws are all and this is Marvel
forgiveness comic forgiveness but my
three biggest flaws are definitely the
fact that she did learn as quickly I
like that she is more Adept but there is
a there is an element of like okay I
would have liked to have seen some
pitfalls in the training every time they
cut to her they were like and success I
would like to say something like build
up to success just for like the hero's
journey is to learn how to blank yeah
and then I did have an issue with the
Titania fight looking like uh lesser but
I also feel like two CGI characters
always gonna look better since CGI was
invented but it was weird that like so I
agree with that being an issue and I
don't know how they're gonna do that
with Daredevil because Daredevil
shouldn't be CGI like I hope that you
know what I mean like so that's gonna be
a thing and then then third I do
definitely feel like they at points were
making her
um only mad at the audience that is
going to be mad at the show but in a way
that it gives them more ammunition like
I I the the MCU crowd has plenty to to
yell about I don't necessarily think
that it's good to poke the bear well
that's why I'm hoping that they will use
those things are you talking to the
women who made the show yes the women
yes let me tell you guys how to do your
job but no for those people who are
gonna be freaking out they're already
gonna be freaking out it's you see you
watch an episode like this and you think
okay so if it's working this is the
thing that makes you upset and that
causes you to take to the internet and
you know harass people you know this
episode is probably going to set you off
and repel you immediately to the point
where you're probably not gonna make it
to episode two so it's just a curiosity
for me of what the intent is and what
the awareness level is of that because I
think yeah it's like this is a good
place to have some of these
conversations and it's a good character
to mix with these you know experiences
and stories you know while in the high
concept setting but yeah like in this
sort of post post-woke post Mary Sue
world that we live in I feel like you
almost have to bring a certain level of
additional awareness or else you are
just making it clear like no this show
is only for yeah she was a guy I would
have the exactly I hope whoever's been a
viewer of us long enough now knows that
we are being honest when we say if that
was a guy we would have the exact same
qualms yeah and I don't want them to
coddle to [ __ ] by making it anything
less because that's the character but I
also don't want a character in any
training montage to not learn
yeah it makes it makes it less
interesting and less cathartic and
rewarding it's just like I'm just kind
of watching I'm using stuff now and it's
always it's like the philosophies and
stuff and her whole thing about the
reasoning of why she is so adaptable
like it all makes sense and I hope
people are able to see the themes past
the surface level stuff but I think
we're going to be getting a different
struggle for her hopefully
I've adjusted at this pretty well and
everyone loves me I like law and Justice
and being a home now I'm a very
successful lawyer
everything's great everything's great
yeah
um and and uh going off the VFX I think
that I think what they really got to
handle on with her
um is the when they were like keeping
her a little shadowed when it was really
bright like like we're just out in the
bright Sun on a beach that's when I'm
like okay it's it's still like but I
it's not Marvel forgiveness this is just
a VFX artist struggle forgiveness and
knowing everything that's been coming
out which seems to be so compounding at
this point I I am like I'm Not Really
Gonna harm it I can tell that's a
She-Hulk yeah like that's nice now it's
now I'm so aware of the conversation
surrounding it that a lot of the time
I'm like that looks good looks good
looks good that doesn't look so good
that doesn't look good now looks good it
looks good it looks good damn it that
freaking conversation just going off in
my head now when I'm watching it this
gave me the experience I hoped for where
it is like it is in a lot of ways like a
piece of makeup it's like I can tell
they probably there is a performance
happening they use probably the eyes
especially to bridge the gap and yes
some sequences look better than others
but even with a great prosthetic
sometimes you can sit there go I can
tell it's a prosthetic but the
performance is endearing and all the
scene work is great so you I saw past
that pretty easily yeah because you're a
better man than me and I was aware that
women made all the VFX on this show all
women man they can't do it I have no
idea
they can't do it that's why the siege
takes so long
um anyway guys what did you think of
She-Hulk if you've made it this far
leave your thoughts down below do you
think koi is a sexist hashtag koi's not
a sexist hashtag soy koi it's gonna go
so well for me don't worry I can tell
most viewers try to make it this far cry
forward to most is the public discourse
surrounding what should otherwise be a
very pleasant experience good show we'll
have nine weeks of content and so will
us or another side of the internet we'll
have nine weeks of content and don't
actually watch the show
subscribe leave a like let's do a
patreon the day shout out before we get
the hell out of here yeah
all right Anissa Oliva number one Mary
Sue at the Patriots if there's anyone
who's a Mary Sue at our patreon page
it's you everything comes so easy to you
you're just so great at everything
you're so smart you don't need to work
hard at all money just you just open up
an envelope like look at all my
boatloads of money you don't have to
work two full-time job wise alcohol at a
great sacrifice weekend hours in order
just to freaking pay off some bills or
help out with the family no everything's
as easy peasy Breezy for you everything
that's a nice patreon
love you no niece we love you you're a
tough ass cookie you struggle in our
nuanced character too say something nice
Coy I don't know you but I like your
name and you've got a lot of vowels in
it
that's good yeah like Tatiana maslani
Alexandra or Mark Ruffalo
he's the member
if you remember Marvel actors mark
people are gonna think I'm calling you
tits
Chris
Chris maslani Chris there's not enough
Chris's in the MCU
I like making jokes that are very
minimally provocative I'm just so so
minimal and I read the one wrong comment
and I'm like I'm pissed off someone else
hurt their feelings I've done [ __ ] up
all right let's regulate your feelings
[Music]